vous savez monsieur Bardella m'a dit la
même chose j'ai débattu avec lui l'autre
soir sur le plateau de France 2 et je
lui ai dit chose très simple dit que la
différence entre lui et moi c'est que
moi je suis droite moi je n'ai pas
consigné enfin je n'ai pas déposé un
amendement qui propose de maintenir le
régime spécial de la RATP il y a deux
amendements à l'Assemblée nationale il y
en a un du groupe du Rassemblement
national pour dire il faut maintenir le
régime spécial de la RATP c'est-à-dire
que le chauffeur de bus parisien il part
10 ans plus tôt que le chauffeur de bus
niçois ou ou lyonnais ou marseillais et
il y en a un autre qui est déposé par
Monsieur Ruffin et tous les insoumis et
bien moi quand je vois
l'irresponsabilité de ce projet le c'est
quoi le projet du rassemblement national
sur les retraites il coûte je crois 37
milliards d'euros et celui des insoumis
60 ce n'est pas responsable moi je suis
pour dire la vérité je suis pour le pas
pour la démagogie permanente bien sûr
c'est plus facile de dire aux Français
vous travaillez moins vous partez à 60
ans la retraite à 60 ans elle a coûté
2000 milliards d'euros au pays on aurait
quasiment
deux tiers de dette en moins aujourd'hui
voilà merci et mais il faut dire la
vérité il faut être courageux c'est bien
le loto tout le monde merci